Bien, en este video vamos a hablar de las
gráficas de posición para el movimiento rectilíneo
uniformemente variado, que también conocemos como
movimiento rectilíneo uniformemente acelerado.
Son dos formas de llamar al mismo concepto,
como ocurre con frecuencia en la ciencia o en
otras actividades que hacemos. Y vamos a empezar
recordando cuál es la expresión matemática para
este tipo de movimiento, y es: la posición x de un
móvil en cualquier momento, es la posición inicial
x₀ + la velocidad inicial de subíndice 0 (v₀),
multiplicada por el tiempo t más un medio (1/2) de
la aceleración por el tiempo t al cuadrado (t²).
En este caso estamos hablando de movimiento
rectilíneo, un tipo de movimiento particular
en una sola dimensión sobre una línea recta
que puede ser vertical u horizontal, y lo hacemos
así en los cursos de Física para presentarlo de la
manera más simple. Es una buena idea simplificada
lo que estamos estudiando para entenderlo mejor,
y también mencionamos que estamos hablando de
un móvil, y nos referimos o llamamos móvil a
un objeto que se mueve, un objeto en movimiento
que queremos estudiar. No creas que esa palabra
sólo se usa para los teléfonos, los objetos
se pueden mover de distintas maneras. Cuando
caminas con un paso regular, podemos decir que
la velocidad es constante y que avanzas la misma
distancia en el mismo lapso de tiempo: 1, 2, 3,
4. Pero este ejemplo corresponde a un movimiento
rectilíneo uniforme con velocidad constante; si
tenemos velocidad constante, no hay aceleración.
Recuerda que sólo hay aceleración cuando cambia
la magnitud o la dirección de la velocidad. El
movimiento rectilíneo uniformemente acelerado es
un movimiento con aceleración constante. Podemos
pensar en un objeto que cae en la Tierra, en
donde la aceleración gravitacional es constante,
o un automóvil que acelera de forma constante
utilizando su motor. Cuando hablamos de gráficas
de posición contra tiempo, utilizamos ejes
coordenados en los que normalmente ponemos
el tiempo en el eje horizontal y la posición
en el eje vertical, como los tenemos aquí,
y vamos a hacer gráficas con la expresión para
el movimiento rectilíneo uniformemente variado,
es decir, esta expresión. Y ¿esta expresión nos
recuerda algo?, ¿se parece a alguna expresión
que ya conocemos? Sí, ya hemos visto este tipo
de expresión en nuestros videos de álgebra,
y corresponde a una ecuación de segundo grado, una
cuadrática, ya que tiene la forma ax² + bx + c. Si
esto no te suena familiar, te invito a que revises
los videos de cuadráticas en Khan Academy. Ya
sabemos que las gráficas de las cuadráticas son
parábolas, por lo que las gráficas del movimiento
rectilíneo uniformemente variado serán un brazo de
una parábola. Es un buen momento de preguntarnos
¿cómo se verá la gráfica en algunos ejemplos
concretos?, ¿cómo cambia la gráfica si variamos
la aceleración?, ¿qué pasa si la aceleración
es positiva?, ¿qué pasa si es negativa?
Vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos utilizando una
calculadora gráfica; ésta es una herramienta
muy poderosa que te invito a utilizar. Yo voy a
usar Desmos, que es un excelente sitio web. Ya
tengo preparada una hoja con la expresión para
el movimiento rectilíneo uniformemente variado,
también tenemos los ejes coordenados, el tiempo t
está en el eje horizontal y la posición x está en
el eje vertical, y también puse unos deslizadores
que controlan los valores de la posición inicial
x₀, la velocidad inicial v₀ y la aceleración
a. Te propongo que hagamos varias gráficas para
distintos valores en nuestra expresión, pero
empecemos con algunos valores que nos permitan
realizar los cálculos con facilidad. El primer
ejemplo será con una posición inicial x₀ = 0,
velocidad inicial v₀ = 0 y aceleración
constante igual a 2m/s². Sensacional. Lo
primero que podemos observar es que el brazo de
la parábola se extiende hacia arriba, el móvil
va recorriendo mayor distancia en cada intervalo
de tiempo, pero vamos a usar la gráfica para saber
la posición del móvil en cada momento. Veamos:
en el primer segundo el móvil avanzó 1 metro;
en el segundo segundo avanzó 3 metros más, pasó de
1 a 4; en el tercer segundo avanzó 5 metros más,
de 4 a 9, y en el cuarto segundo avanzó 7
metros más, de 9 a 16 metros, y así seguirá
incrementando su posición con el tiempo de acuerdo
al comportamiento de las ecuaciones cuadráticas.
¿Qué es lo que está pasando? En cada intervalo de
tiempo aumenta la distancia que recorre el móvil,
se está moviendo más rápido, su velocidad aumenta
debido a la aceleración positiva. Escogí estos
valores en particular para la posición inicial
velocidad inicial y aceleración constante
porque podemos hacer los cálculos con facilidad y
comprobar lo que muestra la gráfica. Bueno, aparte
que otra ventaja que tenemos con esta hoja, es
que nos muestra también una tabla con los cálculos
para algunos puntos de la gráfica. Veamos, en este
caso, tanto la posición inicial como la velocidad
inicial son cero, así que estos términos se
cancelan; para el tiempo t = 0, este término es 0,
1/2 a por cero es cero y el resultado es cero.
Si t = 1, entonces un medio de a, que es dos,
resulta en 1, y 1² es uno, uno por uno es uno, y
es lo que tenemos aquí. Si t = 2, entonces 1/2a,
que es 2, resulta en 1 y 2² es 4, 4 • 1 es 4, y
es lo que tenemos aquí. Parece que todo funciona.
Podríamos seguir así con todos los valores de t.
Hagamos otro ejemplo. Vamos a ver qué pasa ahora
si cambiamos la posición inicial de 0 a 20 metros.
Primero reflexionemos qué estamos haciendo:
tenemos la misma aceleración constante a de 2
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado y la velocidad
inicial sigue siendo 0, la posición inicial cambió
de 0 a 20, pero la posición inicial no afecta la
aceleración ni velocidad del movimiento, así
que observamos cómo la gráfica subió en el
eje vertical, justo como lo esperaríamos. Y si
pensamos un poco más, la posición tendrá que
cambiar en esa misma cantidad para cada uno de los
puntos de la gráfica. Si observamos la gráfica y
la tabla con los cálculos, podemos apreciar que
ocurrió lo que esperábamos: todos los valores
para la posición se desplazaron 20 metros,
y podemos usar la gráfica para encontrar la
posición del móvil en cada momento; en el segundo
0 el móvil está en 20 metros; la posición inicial
en el segundo 1 está en 21, cambió en 1 metro; en
el segundo número 2 pasó a la posición 24 metros,
incrementó en 3 metros; en el segundo número
3 está en 29 metros, con un incremento de 5,
y así podríamos seguir y seguir. Muy bien.
En estos ejemplos que hemos estado haciendo,
la aceleración va en el mismo sentido que el
movimiento: hemos usado una aceleración positiva.
¿Pero qué pasará si usamos una aceleración
negativa? La aceleración negativa va en sentido
contrario. Veamos qué pasa. Vamos a imaginar que
lanzamos una pelota hacia arriba desde el suelo,
como cuando jugamos con una pelota, y esta vez
vamos a usar una aceleración de -2m/s². Otra
vez estoy escogiendo valores que faciliten
los cálculos en la expresión que tenemos.
Imaginemos que este es un planeta especial con
una aceleración gravitacional de -2m/s². Dijimos
que estamos lanzando una pelota hacia arriba, así
que necesitamos una velocidad inicial de 10 metros
sobre segundo, y el lanzamiento está ocurriendo
desde el suelo, así que la posición inicial es 0.
¿Qué grafica obtenemos ahora? Bueno, justo lo que
esperábamos: una parábola que abre hacia abajo.
Vamos a analizar algunos puntos de la gráfica.
Ahora podemos ver que en el segundo 0, al inicio,
la posición es 0: estamos en el suelo; en el
segundo 1 la pelota alcanza una posición altura
de 9 metros. !Wow, va rápido esa pelota! En el
segundo 2, incrementó 7 metros hasta la posición
de 16 metros a partir del suelo, y en el segundo
número 3 el incremento fue de 5 metros. Vemos con
cuidado cómo ha sido el cambio de posición
en cada segundo: primer segundo, 9 metros;
segundo 2, 7 metros; tercer segundo, 5 metros;
en el cuarto podemos ver que es de 3 metros,
y en el quinto segundo es de 1 metro. Por lo que
esta vez, en este caso que tenemos aceleración
negativa, el móvil se desplaza menos en cada
unidad de tiempo, eso es lo que esperábamos:
la aceleración negativa está en dirección
contraria al movimiento y produce un cambio de
posición menor en cada unidad de tiempo. En cada
segundo el móvil inicia con una velocidad inicial
y se va reduciendo en cada unidad de tiempo, la
velocidad del móvil disminuye cada vez más lento
y su cambio de posición es menor. Para finalizar,
utilizando la gráfica, podemos saber cuánto tiempo
le tomará al móvil llegar a cualquier posición.
Por ejemplo, para que la pelota de este ejemplo
llegue a la posición de 25 metros, en este caso es
la altura ya que lanzamos hacia arriba, buscamos
el punto en la gráfica que está en el valor de 25,
en el eje vertical, la posición, y podemos ver que
la coordenada horizontal de ese punto corresponde
a 5 segundos, es decir, le tomó 5 segundos al
móvil para llegar a una altura de 25 metros.
Un móvil con una velocidad inicial de 10 metros
sobre segundo y una aceleración de -2m/s², que en
este caso sería la gravedad, o un valor especial
que le dimos para este ejemplo, y que es lanzado
hacia arriba. Veamos otro punto más, ¿qué tal el
que se encuentra en la posición a 16 metros?
Bueno, pues es éste que está aquí, y podemos
observar que su coordenada horizontal, el tiempo,
es de 2 segundos, así que a este móvil, con estas
condiciones, tardó 2 segundos para llegar a 16
metros. Muy bien, nos vemos en el siguiente video.